[Music]
today's the 36 birthday of missing
American journalist Austin Tice like the
last several birthdays he will not be
celebrating with his family theis a
Marine Corps veteran was abducted in
Syria in August of 2012 five years ago
this weekend no group has claimed
responsibility a video released five
weeks after his disappearance showed him
alive we met Thais his parents in their
hometown of Houston learn why they're
hopeful about their son's return these
are among the last images Austin's heist
captured inside Syria before he was
abducted they show the intensity of it
then literally young civil war we're
hearing some automatic gunfire and stuff
from the surrounding area which Thais
was documenting is a journalist between
the cells for McClatchy the Washington
Post CBS News and others the next and
last the world saw him he was being led
away blindfolded it's always there right
you can't vacation it away you can't
think it away it's what prompts us to
keep working Marc and Debra Tice have
seven children but Austin is their
oldest they've made multiple trips to
the Middle East
Deborah even lived in Damascus for a
time trying to secure his release this
administration is all in fifth gear
let's bring him home and that that does
make a difference in our in our everyday
thinking and that's different from the
previous administration the previous
administration was committed and they
realized that it was on the to-do list
but they weren't pushing it at the list
and you believe it's being pushed now
yes I do
the push for US hostages around the
world to be released received a new and
grisly impetus in june after american
student otto warmbier was returned by
north korea in a coma and died days
later how confident are you that he's
alive a hundred percent absolutely no
doubt yeah no doubt and it's not just us
that's not just parental wishes that's
the assessment of everybody involved in
his situation in a statement issued to
CBS News a State Department spokesman
writes his case has the attention of the
highest levels in the US government and
the administration we are actively
working to bring Austin Tice home where
do you believe he is right now we really
believe that he's in Damascus we know
that he's in Syria you've been to
Damascus are you gonna go back we will
go to Damascus if we're allowed to go do
you allow yourself to visualise him
being freed yes how to visualise
immediate read yes I didn't know whether
that would be helpful or torture it's
absolutely the thing I mean no no again
we will never know Austin as anything
except a free man
that's the only way we'll ever know him
the first thing that Isis a home flooded
a couple years ago they haven't fixed it
because they've been so laser focused on
trying to get their son back and doing
everything they can and and it's it's
extraordinarily difficult for them on a
daily basis because they pay attention
to every development in the news hoping
that something is they'll get some piece
of good news
and there are so many missing Syrians in
those jails and missing foreign
nationals and it is heartening to see
such an effort made for this American
they raised that exact same point they
say that we realize we are one of many
so many families missing children in the
Middle East and around the world their
strength is really impressive great work
thank you yeah